PROFESSOR: What is gamma?
Well, it seems to have
a beta in there, alpha.
It's a little unclear
what gamma means,
so let's try to
make sense of it.
Gamma has units of energy,
because this term has
units of energy, and
therefore the other term
must have units
of energy as well.
So gamma has units of energy.
And from a unit of energy
you could get a time.
So tau, you can define
it as h over gamma.
That has units of time.
h bar has units of
energy times time,
so if you divide by energy,
you get units of time.
And what is this number?
So this is some time.
And it's equal to m
over 2 alpha beta h bar.
We have this guy.
So the natural
thing, of course, is
to compare to the time delay
associated due to this process
that we've been studying.
So all the time delay,
delta t, was 2 h bar dE--
no, d delta dE.
And this is 2 h bar dk
dE times d delta dk.
Now, d delta dk, we calculated
it up on the blackboard.
So this was equal to--
this had been calculated as
1 over beta at resonance.
At the resonance, this time
delay is calculated above,
and it's equal to 1 over beta.
This thing is also
easily calculated,
because this is 1
over dE dk, which
is h bar squared k over m.
Therefore, what do we get?
2 h bar divided
by h bar squared.
k, you're at rest so that's
alpha over m, m here.
And d delta dk is a beta.
So what do we get here?
Delta t is 2m over
h bar alpha beta.
And compare with this
one, it's 4 times tau.
So h over-- so
the end conclusion
is that h bar over
gamma, which is a time,
is tau, which is equal
to delta t over 4.
So that's the intuition
for the half width.
So in the distribution of
this scattering amplitude,
there's a half width.
It's an energy distribution.
And there's a time
associated with it, which
is h bar over the half width.
And, being a time,
it must be related
to some physical time
that has a period,
and there's nothing
else than the delay.
So if the delay is
large, gamma is small,
and the width is small.
It's a narrow resonance.
So a narrow resonance is one in
which the width is very small.
So this has enormous
applications.
It's used in nuclear
physics all the time.
It's used in particle
physics as well.
The Higgs-Boson was
discovered over a year ago,
it's a particle
but it's unstable.
It decays very fast.
If you thought in
terms of that, it just
gets created by
a reaction, stays
in the well for a little
while, and poof, disappears.
So its mathematics
in cross-sections
is governed by resonances.
So we call the Higgs
particle a particle,
but anything that is
unstable it's more like, more
precisely viewed as an object
that represents a resonance.
The Higgs particle
doesn't live too long.
Lives about 10 to
the minus 22 seconds.
Very little time.
And then it decays and it goes
into b-bbar, bottom bottom bar
quark.
As it goes into z's, it
goes into tau lambda.
So it goes into two photons.
It can decay into
all these things.
So in the case of
the Higgs-Boson,
the center energy
of the resonance
is observed in scattering
amplitudes at a center energy E
alpha of 125 GEv.
The width is very small.
In fact, the width is
about gamma, it's about 4
MEv plus minus 5%.
4 MEv, that's very
little, because an MEv
is 1/1000 of a GEv.
So it's a very narrow resonance.
And from this gamma,
you can get a time.
And the time is lifetime.
It's about 10 to the
minus 22 seconds.
So this is the language
that we use to describe
any unstable particle.
We think of it as resonance.
It's sometimes called resonance.
And the title of papers
that appear at that time
is the resonance observed in
the data, the Higgs-Boson.
And the answer was yes.
This was observed
as a resonance.
It is a scattering
amplitude that is uniform,
and it has some energy,
has a little peak.
You can imagine
people can't quite
measure the width directly.
It's too narrow.
So the plots don't
show the width,
but the width is implied, and
there's related calculations
over here with the lambda.
So it's all a nice story.
OK.
So look what we've done.
We began by discussing
that we could not get
time delays that were negative.
Times advance, then we
get long time delays,
and that's a resonance.
We showed that they
correspond to changes,
rapid changes of delta in
the positive direction.
And we've modeled them
so that in general, we
have a general
description of what's
happening near a resonance.